voit le premier ministre edouard
philippe il m'a qui me font rire ce week
end
capable audition il a raconté une blague
il a faim lapsus il a oublié le nom du
président où il a vu jacques chirac à
béziers on patrick chirac est ce qui
s'est passé samedi basque à votre avis
les ouvriers le nom du président non non
il a il attendait alors en fait pour
donner la bonne réponse il faut que
j'arrive à faire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m
et parce que la france est une nation
qui veut continuer à succès de grange ou
parce que la france est une nation
pardon qui veut continuer à susciter des
grands champions dans tous les domaines
les jeux olympiques d'hiver loin encore
des mondes
on me dit que les amateurs de rugby ont
parfois l'esprit mal placé
ceux de bâle iii voilà voilà
aflac je redevienne certes on traduira
pas en anglais cette remarque on la
gardera en français il met la salle avec
lui dans la presse ça c'est bon alors le
donc çà çà çà çà çà quand on n'en a pas
oui je trouvais ça c'est très marrant
parce qu'on a le plein des lapsus 1 il
ya eu un lapsus dans le jt de france 2
cdh on se souvient tous d'un
présentateur qui s'est trompé au moment
d'annoncer une page de pub regardez ça
c'est maintenant notre concours avant la
première page de [ __ ] et de pub à la
[Applaudissements]
deuxième place du top 3 c'est rachida
dati mrap et rachida dati soit jeté
dessus j'appelle elle se souvient très
bien
ah oui la fellation l'a fait qu'elle n'a
pas s'endormir le soir quand je vois
certains qui demandent des rentabilités
à 20 25 % avec une fellation quasi nulle
et en particulier en période de crise
[Applaudissements]
comme une lettre à la poste ça passe
parce qu'on s'en fout là que l'homme
sont en première position c'est dans le
jour du seigneur
un prêtre avait fait un lapsus en
voulant prononcer l'expression se serrer
les coudes
justement pour
pour ne pas se sentir seul des choses en
des prêtres se rend compte assez
régulièrement pour partager sur ce
qu'ils vivent au quotidien
même si on est peu nombreux voilà on se
serre les coudes découdre
non mais je crois quand dominique voynet
elle avait dit exactement la même
réplique il fallait se serrer des
couilles ah ouais là d'éviter un curieux
comme ça c'est oui c'est un autre est en
train pas là dedans